ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des solidarités de l'autonomie
et des personnes handicapées depuis
plusieurs années maintenant les
directeurs des pâtes font face à une
grave pénurie de personnel pour
effectuer leur mission de soins et des
couteaux prêts des résidents dans des
conditions optimales un ehpad devrait
compter un personnel pour une personne
âgée en perte d'autonomie sera jsio est
aujourd'hui de 0,6 pour un entraînant un
profond mal-être des soignants et des
familles bien insuffisants au regard des
besoins en effet le personnel soignant
doit faire face à une surcharge de
travail qui impactent la qualité des
soins apportés aux personnes âgées le
manque d'effectifs suffisants se traduit
par une détérioration des conditions
d'accueil au point que certains
résidents sont douchées que tous les
quinze jours dans certains
établissements les directeurs en sont à
demander de l'aide aux familles pour
donner les repas ou effectuer les
toilettes comment vieillir dignement
dans de telles conditions et pourtant le
personnel des ehpad multiplient les
heures supplémentaires patients d'un
patient à l'autre à une vitesse qui a
dans ses relances ont même à prendre des
congés faute de remplaçant à bout de
souffle épuisés moralement et
physiquement par la dégradation de leurs
conditions de travail de plus en plus de
soignants sont en arrêt maladie ou
choisissent de démissionner ce
diagnostic nous le connaissons vous le
connaissez monsieur le ministre j'ai
d'ailleurs publié dimanche une tribune à
ce sujet avec le professeur jules vingt
et une quarantaine de collègues monsieur
le ministre en cette période estivale la
pénurie personnel dans les ehpad va
encore s'aggraver aussi quelle
thérapeutique envisagez vous de mettre
en oeuvre pour revaloriser les
conditions de travail des soignants dans
les ehpad et ainsi permettre à nos aînés
de vieillir dignement quand allons-nous
enfin débattre d'une loi sur la
dépendance qui devait être un des plus
grands sujets du précédent quinquennat
je vous remercie